Oh, we have new polling data from the 2020
Democratic primary.
The data is good for Joe Biden.
It's good for Elizabeth Warren and it's actually
not so good for Bernie Sanders.
And I know people are sick of me saying this,
but I'm not supporting Joe Biden.
I am merely telling you what the polling data
says.
I did a story earlier this week saying, hey,
Biden in his first 24 hours raised more money
than anybody else in the 2020 Democratic primary
in the first 24 hours.
And he did it from fewer donors with a larger
average donation.
And I got a ton of emails and tweets and comments
saying, David, why are you shilling for Joe?
I'm just reporting to you what the numbers
are.
Okay.
And likewise, I'm reporting to you that we
have new polling data that is from after Joe
Biden announced that he's running for president.
Okay?
The morning consult tracking poll, which surveys
500 registered voters weekly has Biden up
to 36% support since he announced his candidacy.
This is among Democratic primary voters nationally,
Biden at 36% Bernie in second place with 22%
and Elizabeth Warren also actually getting
a bit of a bump up to 9% she was in like three
to 5% in a lot of Poles for awhile.
She's now more intellect, the six to 12 range
depending on which poll you look at.
Uh, so she's rising and this is not the best
news for Bernie Sanders.
Bernie Sanders still very, very strongly in
second place, but Bernie had actually been
pulling as high as the mid to high twenties.
He's now down to 22% and even lower in some
recent polls.
So he's suffered in the last seven to 10 days,
but still a very solid second place and there's
a very long time to go.
Whether you're in first, second, or third
place right now, even fourth place, you can
make the argument still all very well positioned
to ultimately take the lead.
But you know who this is all really bad for
its other establishment Democrats.
The day that Joe Biden announced last week,
I told you this isn't good for Kamala Harris.
This isn't good for Beto O'rourke.
Anybody who is playing the more moderate centrist
role in the Democratic primary, it's not good
that Biden has announced he is going to consolidate
the establishment sort of center left vote
and it's being out to a tee.
Camela Harris had been previously a polling
as high as 15 in February, sort of bounced
around between 10 and 13 since then.
Camilla Harris is now down to just eight in
a recent Quinnipiac poll down to seven in
the recent morning consult poll Beto or Rourke,
he had actually been polling as high as 11
in mid to late March.
Beto is down to between four and six in the
most recent four-poles Biden's announcement
has not been good for Beto and then sort of
unaffected by Biden running are a whole bunch
of people who are still polling as low as
zero and as high as two.
Uh, Andrew Yang got up to three in one poll.
Recent polls haven't met either one or two.
Uh, who Leanne Castro is basically at 1% across
the board.
Tulsi Gabard actually pulled zero in the last
Quinnipiac poll.
Got a 1% in the last morning consult poll.
And as I've said before, um, several months
ago we were at a point where the polling was
not yet accurately indicative of who is likely
to really be in the running.
By the time the primaries get going.
It was a little early.
We're now kind of starting to get into the
pre summer phase.
Um, at which point the polls do start to give
us a hint as to who's a contender.
And we're starting to see this four way may
be five way race, Bernie, uh, sorry, in, in
descending order, Biden, Bernie Warren, Budaj
edge and maybe Kamala Harris, if she can consolidate
some of that non Biden sort of establishment
centrus support doesn't mean things can't
change.
We're just now starting to see who seems to
be completely unable to get traction and who
is emerges emerging as this kind of a, a leaderboard.
And we'll see by June 1st I think we're actually
going to have a much more solid idea of what
a, what it's looking like.